hello
and welcome to this video this is
a black game um playing
very dick verdic we don't know
and maybe we get a dirty harry right now
we get one
so we'll see what verdict is playing
to make up his mind having no
theoretical knowledge to rely on
this is one of those lines that
can lead to very fun complications
okay rook b8 and now what
it kind of helps if you know this stuff
and they do
castle in queenside queen b4 and white
resigns
i try to remember the best move here i
think it's
h3 h3
and then g5 yeah that that's over
already
but what did you think about then
did what did you think about i don't
know this is this
is completely lost
yeah that's dirty harry for you yeah i'm
not going for a rematch i'd rather
show you some ideas of the opening um
just to see what it does this is all
about so
h5 that's more than just the troll move
i can absolutely assure you
um so knight takes e6 is the move that
i face quite frequently and this is not
the first game that i won with no time
spent
it's so tricky so knight xc6 um
people seem to be tempted by this
sequence of moves
to attack the knight and of course i'm
not going back i rather jump to g4
and um here white's
main decision is how to cover e5
um i have faced bishop f4 f4
and queen e2 those are the most logical
moves
here queen e2 was played and the
interesting thing is that here
there's a choice between queen to c7 and
queen to a5
queen to c7 is not a terrible move
but then f4 is good for white it seems
yeah it is better actually to play queen
a5
and the reason here is the following we
attack this
and what exactly is white supposed to do
bishop f4 is met with the game
continuation
f4 is the alternative and after f4
black has the fascinating possibility to
play d5
and this is very interesting we put up
this idea
and also prepare to play the bishop out
and the key point is that if they take i
play rook
h6 and this is dirty harry
h5 prepares rook h6 to e6
this is one of the coolest ideas that
i've seen in recent times
and white is now struggling to stay in
the game
i recently had a blitz game before i
restarted
the daily blitz games that happened with
this
h3
and mate i've had so many
quick knockouts with the dirty harry i
cannot count
so he played bishop f4 rook b8 then
and now white is in some trouble the
best move for white now is relatively
speaking
h3 and this is at least setting a trap
i had one game before i analyzed the
whole thing
where i took here and after bishop d2
all of a sudden i was in trouble
because my knight is attacked and knight
d1
threatens to win material yeah it's a
discovery on the queen
and here black is actually in huge in
huge trouble
in that game i tried this move takes
takes
and now the stunner rook h3 winning
decisive material this is a blitz game
that i lost
a while ago and i put in some work
of course for the course and the best
move
after h3 is g5 and black is fine
actually a little bit better this is
probably
the consequence and after coming bishop
g7
black has a huge sorry that was wrong a
huge initiative
focusing on those uh points c3 b2
castling queenside now is answered with
93 check
all this is in the course you know so if
you want to have a fun line and
say and this this is for you um
yeah and he played this and well queen
before is just over
i had this on the board more than once
already in blitz chess
just last sunday had the cineblitz
tournament
and um the double threat here is already
devastating yeah so dirty harry says
still on sale
on jezebel a fun line for your
repertoire thanks for watching